emergency declared by the governor as a
result of the covert 19 pandemic
in accordance with house rule 67 and the
governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is an executive session on senate
bill 26.
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe
and listen contemporaneously to this
meeting however in accordance with the
emergency order
i am confirming that all members of the
committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously
during this meeting through the zoom
electronic meeting platform
and that the public has access to
contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting
by the zoom platform or by telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available
in the house calendar and through the
electronic calendar
on the general court website the notice
for this meeting
complies with house rules and rsa 91-8
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting
should call 271-3600
or email hcs
leg.state
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting
the meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled i want to introduce the
staff that are
on the meeting assisting us brad
greenland our committee researcher
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting
shall be done by roll call vote let us
start the meeting by taking
a roll call attendance when a member
states their present
please also state whether there is
anyone in the room with you during the
meeting
which is required under the right to
know law
mr clerk if you call the role chairman
representative abbott here in the
community room
representative klasik
great representative boards
present at home with my dog no one else
representative bunker present at home
alone
representative clutier present in the
committee room
representative brassy i'm president
at home alone representative evil
uh home alone in new london
representative edgar a present home
alone here in hampton
representative faulkner malone and
swansea
my wife and may return shortly
representative philippe
my wife is in the house somewhere
chairman graham
uh president in the committee room
representative jack
i'm here in the committee room
representative
representative kaczynski uh
representative kasinsky is having
technical difficulties and i understand
he's on my way
on his way over to my house now so he'll
be joining
me when he gets here
okay thank you representative kolansky
representative kolansky
representative mcconkey um
good morning uh mark mcconkey in freedom
home office
my son is here in the office jake also
representative mills is here and taking
attendance
representative newman yes present
at home in nashua in the room alone
representative newton yeah here in
rochester
by myself again soon to be joined by
representative kaczynski i believe
thank you representative please uh have
him uh
chime in when he gets here so i can
update this well there we are
representative peterson
present at home in nashua alone
representative quarry present
at home in manchester my grandparents
are downstairs
representative sumero am
president i am
representative thompson president of the
committee
representative vande castillo i'm sorry
that's your
representative
you can hear me yes
representative boyd hi this is bill boyd
i'm in my home office in merrimack new
hampshire my daughter and my two dogs
are somewhere else in the house
thank you very much do we have mr
representative kaczynski yet
no we don't okay
all right um a couple of administrative
things
before we get started on the actual
executive session
um hopefully everybody has read the
calendar
on when the house will be meeting and
where
we'll be meeting the third and fourth of
june to go over all senate bills
uh we will be meeting on the 10th of
june
and also in bedford to go over
senate messages on house bills of what
they have
amended or or not and then
on the 24th after committing to
conference we'll be
voting on committee of conference
reports uh remember that on both the
10th and 24th
it's a yay or nay vote we do not offer
amendments at that point
i just wanted to bring that up as far as
executive sessions go
it is for the committee those of you who
are attending virtually
if you raise your hand i'm not going to
recognize you
we have the public hearing two weeks ago
and we have also heard from numerous
other people who have sent
emails to various members of the
committee so this
is a time for the committee to
to work and decide what we are going to
do
with senate bill 26.
that being said um
i will open the executive session on
senate bill 26
and rep uh recognize representative ford
thank you mr chairman i would move that
the committee retained senate bill 26.
i would second that it has been moved
and seconded
uh by representative boyd and
representative thompson that the
committee
retained senate bill 26
retention as everybody remembers
means that we have to do work over the
summer and fall
and the house will vote on our
recommendation
that comes out of that work uh the first
week or two
in january the floor is now open to
discussion
on the motion if you want to speak
please raise your hand
representative mcconkey uh
thank you mr chairman i'm uh i'm in
support
of the of the motion as uh presently
offered
i in my 15 years of committee work
i have never been through such a
hearing as we had at one point i thought
i understood the process
or what the issue was and then to find
an entirely different side to that
i have since that hearing seen many
emails
and people have called for conversations
uh
i'm of the opinion that if we are to
retain this
uh with the energy that's out there uh
that i believe this is a
could come to a resolution without us
having to take action
uh but i vow if if that is not the case
and it does not happen before we bring
this up
uh then i certainly will be in favor of
a different motion
uh so i'm i'm in favor of what is uh
being brought forward
i will vote in support of that mr
chairman
representative philadelphia
unmute please
okay yeah now you're good
i am totally against this i i am i am
for the senate bill
i definitely want to end this i think
the state should
never never be in the position where
they're telling a town how to spend
their tax dollars period i don't think
there's any
that's the way i'm going to vote i just
think it's wrong
and i will be voting against you
thank you anybody else
has representative kozinski made it to
your house yet clifford uh
no i'm still waiting for him as soon as
he if he shows up i'll
get him right on so we can verify he's
here
representative okay thank you maybe this
is a question towards the chair not
necessarily the supporters of the
retention motion
if this committee votes to retain this
bill what do you foresee as a process
for going through retention could you've
got someone have you got some ideas yeah
as i've said at other forums
my intention on this would be to have a
subcommittee
of six three republicans three democrats
i don't get volunteers there's always
the draft
um to work on this
through we can actually start in june
um and part of july august the speaker
usually says no work
but by mid september
third fourth week in september i would
expect a report from that subcommittee
so that the entire committee could meet
and discuss this in october because we
have to
report out at the end of october
roughly um to the entire house for
a vote in january that would be my
intention and i'm sure that i would get
people to to volunteer for
that little bit of additional work um
it may come back with not a great
recommendation or no recommendation
but i think that we need to do that way
representative dude yeah so i'm going to
uh
vote against the motion that's brought
forward i don't think we should kick the
can down the road here it was a 20-3
vote
out of the senate i think this bill is
necessary
and i think the sooner that we get it
and pass it on to the governor the
better
thank you um this is just
everybody else this is not a partisan
issue um
there are members of the committee on
both sides of the issue
of the issue in both parties um so
i fully respect how people are going to
vote represent places
uh yes i just want to say i agree with
representative newton um
i don't see how this gets better by you
know kind of waiting it out
so i i will also vote against the vote
voting against the motion for that
reason
all
first of all many feel the same
i think of the other thing
is that i know nowhere else in new
hampshire
where there were similar funding and
formula issues
involved i think that uh
in my world i only know
of the village we live in the town of
winchester
and the village of spafford in the town
of chesterfield
and i represent
chesterfield in the state of walpole
along with representative weber of
representatives first
representative it would be similar
because the disproportionate number
of the amount of property tax
raised in chesterfield
comes largely from those
homes that have frontage on spotlight
it would be as if the folks came to me
and asked for legislation where they
would get a portion of the property tax
and retire from those homes i certainly
would not sponsor such
legislation i don't think it's our
business
and i think that the other part
the only place where the state should be
involved
in these matters is with the department
of president administration
in the audits which they've been
conducted and which i don't
show necessarily malfeasance on the
woodsville
fire district but certainly big proper
i'm not an attorney
i'm not a certified public accountant
but i don't
um i think that's the portion
they suggest mediation that has
not been successful in the past and i
think that what should happen
again is that this builder ought to pass
and move us from
the situation thank you thank you
representative evil you had your hand up
um if you don't mind i'd like to defer
until i hear what representative
faulkner shares as far as his views on
the subject thank you
he raised it after you represent fox
well thank you mr chairman knight let me
find myself in a
mistake minority but i looked at this
quite carefully i think this has been
mischaracterized as money
being raised by the rest of the town
going to going to the village of
woodsville
if you look at carefully where the money
comes from where it goes the money
that's raised in woodsville goes to
woodsville
raised for highway purposes goes to
woodsville and the money raised
elsewhere goes to the town's highway
department
the uh
the bill is as it stands down the
statute as it now stands basically
is an endorsement of a
agreement that came to us
11 years ago uh
because the formula for dividing up this
money has been
changed slightly over that time but
essentially we're not dictating
a formula where you are you know
including in the
statute the formula that was brought to
us by an agreement between the parties
and this is the way it's going to happen
for all these village districts i mean
that
the state does tell them how how to
raise their money uh
and um
you know as a practical matter maybe
other ways to do this
i would be happy to see a different
agreement come out
but i don't think that we can impose one
party's
view of the agreement on on the two
parties without having
the then go through a process of
mediation and
um you know
in an open and fair negotiation
uh we're just basically picking one
party versus the other
and i don't think that we
have the information to indicate that
that's the right
right way to go so i'm i certainly be in
favor of retaining if this
retention vote doesn't uh doesn't
succeed i'm going to vote against the
bill as a whole thank you
now representative people
thank you i just anyway um
so like all of us i've looked at this
quite a bit in particular i looked at
the um
legislative history going back to you
know
pre-dawn aid or and i also
looked at the litigation summaries i
looked at
the previous iteration of this bill
which was
included in hb 1234 that was vetoed by
the governor
it was introduced in the same way
by senator gaida i would not have uh
supported that version and that
was uh um combining
by statute uh woodsville
and and haverhill and i don't think that
that's
the right approach i realized that it's
historical
that we've been as much involved in what
is going on up there
as as we have been
and i think in 1990 we were trying to
help in 2009
with the current formulation that's in
the statute
we were trying to help
the next time if they come up with
another formulation
if we put it in the statute we'd be
trying to help and then they'd be back
to us perhaps at another time
and i really think that they should be
negotiating out themselves
what their deals are over time
as property values change as
relationships change
i don't see how that is
helped by retaining the bill i mean
i realize that they're in litigation the
litigation
is actually analyzing um how the parties
have related
under the current statute if the parties
negotiate
another formulation i couldn't
in good faith support including that
formulation
in the statute because it could change
again
and then they're bound by it
the if if we pass this and i will say
i'm in favor of passage
um it has to go through the process
it'll go to the governor the governor
probably won't have deal with it until
maybe july or later
the litigation will proceed
i don't see that we're helping one side
or the other by
not passing this at this point because
it's just
a matter of local control and i think
that's just
where it should be i don't see the
state's
interest in being in the middle of this
these two parties don't need a parent
straightening things out for them they
should be
dealing with it on their own and and
just be subject to
the other laws that apply to village
districts which i know very little bit
about
but um that's where so i'll be voting
against the motion to retain
thanks uh representative jack
oh that was true all right that was very
good
foreign
to retain i agree with everybody this
does nothing to fix this problem
and this problem does need to be fixed
no matter what the formula
happens to be in any kind of agreement
that they work out
they should work that formula out and it
should not be in
a state statute it should be liquid
enough that they can change it
as necessary as property taxes and
situations changed
retaining this as far as waiting for the
court case
the court case will more than likely go
into mediation but the mediation
is and the court case is only about
dollars
that are currently owed interpreting
this statute the way it is right now it
does nothing
to fix this problem so once again i am
against the uh retaining motion
and uh i have a little experience
thank you nice
anybody else i see no other hands raised
are we ready to go to the vote on the
motion
to retain
we are the clerk will call the role on
the motion
to retain senate bill 26.
representative mcconkey
i vote no on retaining it no
representative philadelphia no
representative newton no
representative blasey no
representative boards
is representative yet no he isn't
thank you representative thompson
yes representative boyd
lloyd votes no i'm excuse me boy votes
you have to retain i'm sorry yes
i was carried away there i apologize
representative clutier
yes representative edgar
no representative evil
no representative jack no
representative abbott no
representative faulkner yes
representative newman
yep representative newman
sue no
representative grassy no
representative peterson no
representative query no
representative funker no
chairman graham yes
mr chairman the vote motion to retain
the bill fails
when a vote of 15 against 6-4
thank you the motion fails
we still have another motion i recognize
representative mills for a motion
i move make i make the motion that this
bill auto packs has amended
second we didn't make an amendment
this is just
representative mills moves up to pass
on senate bill 26 has been seconded by
representative
abbott is there any further discussion
on the bill
[Music]
representative edgar
saying none of course you'll call the
roll on ought to pass
on senate bill 26.
representative mcconkey
aye clerk folks yes
representative sumero
romero votes yes representative
philadelphia
yes representative newton
yes representative blasey
yes representative boards
yes representative thompson
no representative boyd
point votes on representative clutier
uh yes representative edgar
all right representative evil
yes representative jack yes
representative abbott yes
representative faulkner no
representative newman
yes representative grassy
yes representative peterson
yes
representative query yes
representative funker yes
chairman graham no
[Music]
it's emotional passes with a vote of
to 3. of those who voted
no is there any objection
to the consent calendar is there still a
rule about no more than two no votes
there that was always unofficial there
is no money involved
it can go on to the it's the consent
calendar it's unusual
but the speaker has strongly suggested
we put as many as possible
under the consent calendar
but that having been said i am going to
put it on the regular calendar as i
think about it i am sure that
representative flad
who testified against the bill will want
to speak about it
and so we'll just put it in its regular
place in the calendar
rather than at the end of the calendar
as it gets pulled off of
um consent so we'll be on the regular
calendar as i think this story
um this has been
one of the harder um as representative
mcconkey said one of
the harder bills that we have had in
this committee not
within the house and i want to thank
everybody
for their um diligence and looking at
all of the information that was sent to
us listening to the two hours of
sometimes acrimonious testimony um
and i think that um majority committee
police
we're doing the right thing and that is
why we are here to make
recommendations to the house that said
um we have no
other bills to come before us or
executive sessions
for this year of
the biennium we will probably
have a committee of conference
on senate bill 25 capital budget
because i i having listened to all of
the
agency presentations and the senate
questions and comments
i think that there will be changes to
what we said to them
how extensive they are i do not know um
that i will keep members of the
committee
informed on what those are um i want to
thank
representative rossi you might as well
be a member of the committee
debate every period at every executive
session
thank you i've enjoyed it very much
um so um that's it
anybody else have any comments i told
you about the upcoming sessions
and those are important um
so please attend and
hopefully we can get to see each other
in person on
one of those four days i did have so
much
how did the hearing on the capitol
budget go yes sir
the hearing the public hearing on house
bill 25 was held at 10 am
yesterday it was after as we did it was
after all of the agency presentations
there was one speaker in favor and that
was me
because i introduced the bill there was
nobody else who spoke
and as you can imagine because we heard
some of the same pleas from
agencies agencies asked for additional
money which they are now weighing
as they go forward into their work
sessions
and executive sessions my understanding
if you look at the senate calendar there
will probably be
a senate meeting on the capitol budget
their capital budget committee
next tuesday which you can
zoom in and listen to if you so
any other comments or questions and i
thank all of the committee for
this year's work um that we have had on
the bills we haven't had a lot of bills
but it's been trickier trying to do it
in this hybrid fashion
um because we miss the the camaraderie
around
the tables of of talking to each other
and and probably asking more questions
of people who are
presenting but um thank you all
okay just one final question on the
capital budget if we decide to form a
committee conference to vote
you'll obviously consult the committee
before you know the june 10th session is
that correct um
committees of conference concurs
non-concurrence commit um
request committees conference votes will
all be taken on the 10th of june
okay um
let the committee know what my thoughts
are
on committee of conference once i find
out
what the senate has done um
as former chairs who are sitting around
here know
it is my decision uh whether or not to
to recommend to the house uh what to do
but if you know 22 of the committee
don't want to go that route
i'd be kind of silly to to do that
representative editor mr chairman
i just wanted to thank you for the way
you've uh conducted the committee
in the way that you have this year
really really appreciate it thank you
yay yeah
it's 20 years experience that's all
they finally let me have to gather
any anyone else if not
um the committee will stand adjourned
uh to the call of the chair or call of a
conference committee
if we need to do that i thank you all
for showing up
uh representative newton when
representative kozinski shows up tell
him we're sorry
we missed him
and i know where he was coming down uh
so thank you all
um we can close this up
[Music]